hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to kiss hasta game that
everybody's been requesting if I could
say requesting properly I would be able
to play this game better I don't know
what it's really about besides we
working time
besides pumping gas basically and I know
that there's gonna be something really
strange and interesting and a hook to
this game and then I'm gonna flip my lid
not know what the hell's going on but as
far as I know right now no one seems to
want gasps hey Oh God sorry Jesus
Oh alrighty then oh well I seemed out my
first customers okay
this reminds me of the game Oh God uh
how do i oh oh probably not a good idea
to leak everything everywhere oh oh wait
no sir what are you doing hi Wow alright
then
um I don't know what you want from me I
I think you want gas but I'm not sure
forget it in there quick whoa where to
go oh crap
come on come back here please I don't
know what I'm doing I just got thrown
into the game everybody wants it oh oh
oh now let's go I clicked on it before I
didn't know okay bye umm I needed that
hose sir
what in the hell is going on stop doing
that
whatever you're doing to stop Kenny okay
never mind you know what I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna really question this
anymore because I just woke a I knew you
need to pay for that sir okay um I don't
know what I'm doing I gotta click on it
with the center of the mouse screen okay
I was actually doing that totally wrong
just take your gas put it in your ass
for all case cup god damn it I'm trying
to coordinate everything here it's my
job to make sure that things go smoothly
dang is damn it this doesn't seem proper
at all you just do that hop the wait a
minute sir you back up a step there what
are you doing get it go okay I need to
take a breather because I play these
games to unstress you get me stressed
all up over the place wait what what you
weren't done okay all right yo maybe
it's just best if I stand in the middle
of the road and just take things as they
come my dad I mean totally ruin
everybody else's day obviously my gas
ain't good enough what is in the water
hole hey doesn't go anywhere oh don't
make me turn this car around that's what
this game reminds me of because it was
uh I don't know not kinda like it just
kind of a little bit reminiscent of it I
don't know who's actually gonna take me
anywhere and I remember and don't make
me turn the car around you like started
at a gas station you went up into the
hills it was totally like that or am I
just losing my mind right now
also don't nagy turn this car around was
only my favorite less place that I ever
did this one ha I don't even understand
what I play hit oh that ain't good
oh okay all right whatever you know I'm
just gonna dodge these guys I don't have
a damn hope of filling up the gas I
don't know what you guys are expecting
out of me there's no way I'm just
leaking money all over the place I can't
deal they don't want me to deal saw
goddammit
just cooperate with me hey ah man come
on oh my god damn you get out here if
you don't want to cooperate just give me
the sing oh god it's gonna give me a
hernia
Oh sir I'm trying to pump gas
it's my job God what is this Russia
hahahahaha down to drip it on your car
hope you've burned on the way out
buy whatever are you doing are you doing
you need gas I got gas I got gas for you
I got gas for me okay I was almost there
and I got gas for you no don't move
don't move
god damn it what I to save your sons of
you don't do what I tell ya
you're never gonna go anywhere in life
I'm gonna get one guy pull up if it's
our last say my dough big done yeah the
deal is over yet I want to go home this
job is worth it
I probably brick in 15 bones already
Rifkin you know I'm broken over dunes I
know can you do Pat more gas grow old oh
I thought a fire cut or something is it
almost time for the day to be over what
time was it
2100 well there's no way in hell I'm
gonna get there I'm just gonna watch the
chaos before me
y'all are some silly sons good
job there I'm pretty sure this game was
probably just an experiment
AI programming to make sure that things
did things automatically like I was
completely empty how did he even roll
into here give give give give goddamn it
get to me god damn it give to me thank
you okay never mind then I guess I
wasn't needed anyway okay I guess I
should just stop trying then and I'm not
even holding it anymore
brick give there we go did you like that
did you like that for the few seconds
you had it give it back please okay have
a nice day
it over yet it's almost over oh hello
sorry was I in your way oh excuse me
sorry pardon
another day's almost over don't know
what that means maybe it'll all blow up
work again work again how would anybody
be able to get a high score alright wow
I guess that's my store then so this got
salsa it's an online game totally free
you play for yourself maybe you'll find
it to be a little bit fun I thought it
was very frustrating so you guys can
check it out for yourself thanks again
everybody for watching click the
annotation more videos that I've done
especially watch don't make me turn this
car around it's very funny
check it out you trying thanks again and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye is
a game about trying to get home with my
damn bastard kids done it okay no you
always start out with a book and love it
I was spitting everywhere
Oh